the whole point in learning differential
equations is that eventually we want to
model real physical systems I know
everything we've done so far has really
just been a toolkit of being able to
solve them but the whole reason is that
is that because differential equations
can describe a lot of systems and then
we can actually model them that way and
we know that in the real world
everything isn't these nice continuous
functions so over the next couple of
videos we're going to talk about
functions that are a little bit more
discontinuous than what you might be
used to even in kind of a traditional
calculus or a traditional precalculus
class and the first one is the unit step
function let's write it is U and they'll
put a little subscript C here of T and
it's defined as when T is let me put it
this way it's defined as 0 when T is
less than whatever our subscript I put
here when T is less than C and it's
defined as 1 that's why we call it the
unit step function when T is greater
than or equal to C and if I had to graph
this you could graph it as well but it's
not too difficult to graph let me draw
my x-axis right here and I'll do a
little thicker line that's my x-axis
right there this is my y-axis y-axis
right there and let's and when we talk
about Laplace transforms which we'll
talk about shortly we only care about T
is greater than 0 because we saw our
definition of the Laplace transform
we're always taking the integral from 0
to infinity so we're only dealing with
the positive x-axis but anyway if by
this definition it would be 0 all the
way until you get to some value C so
you'd be 0 until you get to C and then
at sea you jump and the Point C is
included X is equal to C here so it's
included so I'll put a dot there because
it's greater than or equal to C you're
at 1 so this is 1 right here and then
you go forward for all of time and
you're like Sal you just said that
differential equations we're going to
model things why is this type of a
function useful well in the real world
sometimes you do have something that
essentially jolts something that mu
from this position to that position and
obviously nothing can move it
immediately like this but you might have
some some system you know it could be an
electrical system or mechanical system
where where maybe the behavior looks
something like this where it's you know
maybe it moves it like that or something
and this function is a pretty good
analytic approximation for some type of
real-world behavior like this when
something just gets moved whenever we
solve these differential equations
analytically we're really just trying to
get a pure model of something eventually
we'll see that it you know doesn't
perfectly describe things but it helps
describe it enough for us to get a sense
of what's what's going to happen
sometimes it will completely describe
things but anyway let's we can ignore
that for now so let me get rid of these
things right there so the the first
question is well you know what if
something doesn't jar just like that
what if what if I want to construct more
fancy unit functions or or more fancy
step functions let's say I wanted to
construct something that looked like
this let me say this is my this is my
y-axis this is my x-axis and let's say I
wanted to construct something that is at
let's say it's that let me do it a
different color let's say it's at 2:00
until I get to I don't know let's say
it's a 2 until I get to PI until I get
to PI and then from PI until forever it
just stays it it just stays at 0 so how
could i how could I construct this
function right here using my unit step
function so what if let's see what if I
had written it as so my unit step
function is 0 initially so what if I
make it to minus a unit step function
let me say to minus a unit step function
front that starts at PI so if I define
my function here will this work well
this unit step function when we pass PI
is only going to be equal to 1 but we
want this thing to equal to 0 so it has
to be 2 minus 2 so I'll have to put a 2
here and this should work when we go
from when we're at any value below pi
T is less than PI here this becomes a
zero so our function will just evaluate
to two which is right there but as soon
as we hit T is equal to PI that pi is
the C in this example as soon as we hit
that the unit step function becomes one
we multiply that by two and we have two
minus two and then we end up here with
zero now that might be nice and
everything but let's say you wanted to
let's say you wanted it for it to to go
back up let's say that instead of
instead of it going like this instead of
it going like this let me kind of erase
that by over drawing the x-axis again we
want the function to jump up again we
want it to jump up again at let's say
it's some value let's say it's at 2 pi
we want the function to jump up again
how could could we construct this and
let's and we could make it jump to
anything let's say we want it to jump
back to two well we could just add
another unit step function here
something that would have been zero all
along all the way up till this point but
then at 2 pi it jumps so that it would
be in this case our C would be 2 pi so
unit step function we wanted to jump to
2 this would just jump to 1 by itself so
let's multiply it by 2 and now we have
this function so you could imagine you
can make an arbitrarily complicated
function of things jumping up and down
to different levels based on different
essentially linear combinations of these
unit step functions now what if I wanted
to do something a little bit fancier
what if I wanted to do something that
let's say I have some function let's say
have some function that looks like this
let me draw some function that's I
should draw straighter than that I
should have some standards so let's say
that just my regular f of t f of T let
me this is X actually why am i doing X
this would be the T axis we're dealing
the time domain it could have been X but
and then this is call this f of T so let
me draw some arbitrary f of T let's say
my function looks something crazy like
that
now what if I modeling a physical so
this is my F of T
what if I'm modeling a physical system
that doesn't do this that actually at
some point well I say let's say it stays
at zero it stays at zero for until some
value let's say this goes to zero until
I'll call that C again and then at C F
of T kind of starts up so right at C f
of T should start up so it just it kind
of goes like this so essentially what we
have here is a combination of it's zero
all the way and then we have a shifted f
of T so at C we have a shift at F of T
so it shifts that way so how can we
construct this yellow function where
it's essentially a shifted version of
the screen function but it's zero below
C this green function might have
continued it might have gone something
like this it might have you know
continued and done something crazy but
what we did is we shifted it from here
to there and then we zeroed out
everything before C so how could we do
that well just shifting this function
you've learned in your algebra 2 or your
precalculus classes to shift a function
by C to the right you just replace your
T with a t minus C so this function
right here is f of T minus C and to make
sure I get it right what I always do is
I imagine okay what's going to happen
when T is equal to C when T is equal to
C you're going to have a C minus a C and
you're going to have F of 0 so f of 0 is
should be the same so when T is equal to
C this value the value of the function
should be equivalent to the value of the
original green function at 0 so it's
equivalent to that function value which
makes sense if we go up one more above C
so let's say we let's say this is one
more above C so we get to this point
when you if this if T is C plus 1 then
when you put C plus 1 minus C you just
have F of 1 and F of 1 is really just
this point right here and so it'll be
that F of 1 so it makes sense so as we
move one forward here we're essentially
at the same function value as we were
there so
the shift works but I said that we had
to also if I just shifted this function
you would have all this other stuff
because you would have had all this
other stuff when the function was back
here still going on right the function
I'll draw it lightly it would still
continue but I said I wanted to zero out
this function before we reach C so how
can I zero out that function well it's I
think it's pretty obvious to you I
started this video talking about the
unit step function so what if I multiply
the unit step function times this thing
what's going to happen so what if I my
new function I call it the unit step
function up till C of T times f of T
minus C so what's going to happen this
until we get to C right the unit step
function is zero when it's less than C
so you have zero times I don't care what
this is zero times anything is zero so
this function is going to be zero once
you hit C the unit step function becomes
one so once you pass C this thing
becomes a 1 and you're just left with 1
times your function so then your
function can behave is it would like to
behave and you actually shifted it this
t minus C is what actually shifted the
screen function over to the right and
this is actually going to be a very
useful way to look at or very usefully
constructed function and in a second
we're going to figure out the Laplace
transform of this and you're going to
appreciate I think why this is a useful
function to look at but now you
understand at least what it is and and
and and why it essentially shifts a
function and zeroes out everything
before that point well I told you that
this is a useful function so it I we
should add its Laplace transform to our
library of Laplace transforms so let's
do that so let's take the Laplace
transform let's take the Laplace
transform of this of the unit step
function up to C I'm doing it in fairly
general terms in the next video we'll do
a bunch of examples when we can apply
this but we should at least prove to
ourselves what the Laplace transform of
this thing is well the Laplace transform
of anything it's or our definition
so far is the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus s T times our
function so our function in this case is
the unit step function U sub C of T
times f of t minus C DT and it seems
very general it seems very hard to
evaluate this integral at first but
maybe we can make some form of a
substitution to get into a term that we
can appreciate so let's make a
substitution here let me pick a nice a
nice variable to work with I don't know
we're not using an X anywhere which
might as well use an X that's the most
fun variable to work with X sometimes a
lot of you'll see in a lot of math
classes they introduce these crazy Latin
alphabets and that by itself makes it
hard to understand but so I like to stay
away from those crazy Latin alphabets so
we'll just we'll just use a regular ax
let's make a substitution let's say that
X is equal to t minus C right or you
could if we added C to both sides we
could say that T is equal to X plus C
let's see what happens to our
substitution and also if we took the
derivative of this both sides of this
which I or again just a differential you
would get DX is equal to DT I mean if
you took DX with respect to DT you would
get that if T equal to 1 C is just a
constant and if you multiplied both
sides by DT you get DX is equal to DT
and that's a nice substitution so what
is our integral going to become with
this substitution so our integral it's
this was T equals 0 to T is equal to
infinity when T is equal to 0 when T is
equal to 0 what is X going to be equal
to well X is going to be equal to minus
C actually before I go there let me
actually take a step back because I we
could progress let me we could go in
this direction but we could actually
simplify it more before we do that let's
go back to our original integral before
we even made our substitution if we're
taking the integral from 0 to infinity
of this thing we already
what does this integral look like what
does this function look like when it's
zero we have we have this unit step
function sitting right here
we have the unit step function sitting
right there so this whole expression is
going to be zero until we get to C right
this whole thing by definition this unit
step function is zero until we get to
see so this everything's going to be
zeroed out until we get to C so we could
we could essentially say you know we
don't have to take the integral from T
equals zero to T equals infinity we
could take the integral let me write it
here we could take the let me I'll just
use that old integral sign we could just
take the integral from T is equal to C 2
T is equal to infinity of e to the minus
st the unit step function you see if T
times f of t minus C DT in fact at this
point this unit step function is kind of
it doesn't it has no use anymore because
before before T is equal to C it's zero
and now that we're only worried about
values above C it's equal to 1 so it
equals 1 in this context I want to make
that very clear to you what did I do
just here I changed our bottom boundary
from 0 to C and I think you might
realize why I did it when I was working
with the substitution and because this
will simplify things if we do this ahead
of time so for if we have this unit step
function this thing is going to zero out
this entire integral before we get to C
remember this definite integral is
really just the area under this curve
right of this whole function of the unit
step function times all of this stuff
all of this stuff when we multiply it
it's going to be 0 until we get to some
value C and then above C it's going to
be e to the minus st times F of t minus
C so it's going to start doing all this
crazy stuff so if we want to take the
the essentially find the area under this
curve we can we can ignore all the stuff
that happens before C so instead of
going from T equals 0 to infinity we can
go from T is equal to C to infinity
because there is no area before T was
equal to C so that's all I did here and
then the other thing I said is that the
unit step function it's going
to be won over this entire over this
entire range of potential T values so we
can just kind of ignore it right it's
just going to be one this entire time so
our integral simplifies to the definite
integral from T is equal to C 2 T is
equal to infinity of e to the minus st
times F of t minus C DT and this will
simplify it a good bit I was going down
the other Road when I was in the
substitution first which would have
worked but I think the argument as to
why I could have changed the boundaries
would have been a harder argument to
make so now that we had this let's let's
go back and make that substitution that
X is equal to t minus C so our integral
becomes I'll do it in green when T is
equal to C what is X then X is 0 right
C minus C is 0 when T is equal to
infinity what is X well X is you know
infinity minus any constant still going
to be an infinity or the limit as T
approaches infinity X is still going to
be infinity here time and this the
integral of e to the minus s but now
instead of a T we have the substitution
if we said X is equal to t minus C then
we can just add C to both sides you get
T is equal to X plus C so you get X plus
C there and then times the function f of
t minus C but we said t minus C is same
thing as X and DT is the same thing as
DX showed you that right there so we can
write this as DX this is starting to
look a little bit interesting so what is
this equal to this is equal to the
integral from 0 to infinity let me let
me expand this out of e to the minus s X
minus s C times f of X DX now what is
this equal to well we could factor out
an e to the minus SC and bring it
outside of the integral because this has
nothing to do with what we're taking the
integral with respect to so let's do
that let me take let me take this guy
out and make
just just to not confuse you let me
rewrite the whole thing zero to infinity
I could rewrite this Eater Maz II
actually let me write it this way I'll
do what was already in green as e to the
minus s x times e to the minus s see
right common base so if I were to
multiply these two I could just add the
exponents which you would get that up
there times f of X D of X times f of X D
of X this is a constant term with
respect to X so we can just factor it
out we can just factor this thing out
right there so then you get e to the
minus s C times the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus s x times f
of X DX now what what were we doing here
the whole time we were taking the
Laplace transform we were taking the
Laplace transform of we were taking the
Laplace transform of the unit step
function that goes up to see and then
it's 0 up to see it and it's one after
that of T times times some shifted
function f of T minus C and now we got
that as being equal to this thing and we
made a substitution we simplified it a
little bit e to the minus s see e to the
minus s C times the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus s X f of X DX
something about my the tablet doesn't
work properly right around right around
this period but this this this should
look interesting to you
what is this this this is the Laplace
transform of f of X let me write that
down what's the Laplace transform of
well I could write it as f of T or f of
X the Laplace transform of F of T is
equal to the integral from 0 to infinity
of e to the minus s T times f of T DT I
mean the only
and this are the exact same thing we're
just using a tea here we're using an X
here no difference they're just letters
but they're lonely this is f of T this
is f of T e to the minus s T times F of
T DT I could have also very written is
the Laplace transform of F of T I could
write this as the integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the minus s y times f
of Y dy I could do it by anything
because this is a definite integral the
Y's you're going to disappear and we've
seen that all you're left with is a
function of s these this is all this
ends up being some capital well you know
we could write some capital function of
s so this is interesting this is a
Laplace transform of f of t times some
scaling factor and that's what we set
out to show so we can now show that the
Laplace transform the Laplace transform
of the unit step function times some
function t minus C is equal to this
function right here e to the minus s see
where this C is the same as this C right
here times the Laplace transform of f of
t times the Laplace transform I don't
know what's going on with the tablet
right there of f of T let me write that
this is equal to because it's looking
funny there e to the minus s C times the
Laplace transform of F of T so this is
our result this is our result
now what does this mean let's see if we
know look at like backfilled it somehow
what does this mean what can we what can
we do with this well let's say we had
the Laplace transform let's say we
wanted to figure out the Laplace
transform of the unit step function that
starts up at PI of T and let's say we're
taking I don't know something that we
know well sine sine of sine of t minus
pi so we shifted it right
this thing is really malfunctioning at
this point right here let me pause it
I just Paulo sorry if that was a little
disconcerting I just paused the video
because it was having trouble recording
at some point on my little board so let
me rewrite the result that we'd proved
just now we showed that the Laplace
transform the Laplace transform of the
unit step function T and it goes to one
it's some value C times some function
that's shifted by C to the right it's
equal to e to the minus CS times the
Laplace transform of just the unshifted
function that was our result that was a
big takeaway from this video and if this
seems like some Byzantine hard to
understand result we can apply it so
let's say the Laplace transform is this
what I was doing right before the actual
pen tablet started started
malfunctioning if we want to take the
Laplace transform of the unit step
function that goes to one at PI T times
the sine function shifted by PI to the
right we know that this is going to be
equal to e to the minus CS C is PI in
this case so minus PI s times the
Laplace transform of the unshifted
function so in this case it's the
Laplace transform of sine of T and we
know what the Laplace transform of sine
of T is it's just 1 over s squared plus
1 so the plus transform of this thing
here which before this video seemed like
something crazy
we now is we now know is this times this
so it's e to the minus PI s times this
or we can just write it as e to the
minus PI s over s squared plus 1 we'll
do a couple more examples of this in the
next video where we go back and forth
between the Laplace world and the the T
the between the S domain and the time
domain and I'll show you how this is a
very useful result to take a lot of
Laplace transforms and to invert a lot
of Laplace transforms